welcome to the second lecture in our
series on science and cooking and we're
delighted today to have Joanne Chang
this week the topic is phase transitions
now phase transitions is what happens
like when you boil water you know that
when you heat water it goes from being a
normal temperature to being at some
point the liquid transforms to a gas and
there are lots of phase transitions in
cooking I mean in fact arguably cooking
is really the control of phase
transitions and it turns out that one of
the most useful phase transitions for
and really one of the most interesting
for cooking happens with sugar water
which is going to play I think a
prominent role in tonight's lecture and
I mean the thing about sugar water
actually is anyone drinking Coca Cola
does anyone have a Coca Cola you have a
Coca Cola no one will admit it
so I mean well okay so let me ask you a
question maybe in fact I'm not going to
use my slides maybe I'm going to just
talk about phase transitions instead so
I should have brought this demo so does
anybody know if we took is that a beaker
of water
this is ice that's ice so if we took
water that's about how much water is
that that's about it's five and a half
cups of water does anybody know how much
sugar we can dissolve in five and a half
cups of water that is for example
suppose we had another beaker which was
filled with sugar up to this level do
you think if we mixed it in the water it
would dissolve who votes yes who votes
no okay so but most of you didn't vote
did you notice that they didn't vote so
let's try it again you're not allowed to
get away with this so it's a this is a
straightforward question you can go home
and verify it if we had you know five
and a half cups of sugar and we poured
it in five and a half cups of water who
votes that it would dissolve who votes
that it wouldn't dissolve okay so what
if we had five and a half cups of salt
instead of sugar salt so reads the
cooking material right so you use Co
something
who thinks the salt would dissolve who
thinks that the salt would not dissolve
okay so what if we had ten cups of sugar
sugar so that's five and a half cups of
water suppose I had ten cups of sugar
who thinks it would dissolve who thinks
it wouldn't it off okay you're getting
better at voting so the answer is is
that ten cups of sugar would dissolve so
the solubility so you can dissolve twice
the twice the weight of sugar in the
equivalent weight of water at room
temperature now Joanne is going to be
doing a lot of boiling are you going to
be boiling
I am so when you boil suppose you have
water at 100 degrees Celsius boiling
point
how much sugar can you dissolve that
does anybody know I mean maybe I'll ask
it this way so let's say we had eleven
so I'm leading you to the answer but so
we said eleven cups so what about
fifteen cups can you add boiling water
fifteen cups twenty cups who votes
fifteen who says yes twenty who says yes
so it turns out it's four times it's a
factor of four at one hundred degrees
Celsius it's also the case and maybe
this is a better intro than what I had
prepared come to think of it cuz this
might even be relevant for what you're
going to talk about that's unusual right
you know so so it's also the case that I
don't know if you knew this but the
boiling point of sugar water mixtures
increases with temperature so if you
actually were to put four cups of sugar
of sugar in to a cup of water at a
hundred degrees Celsius the water
wouldn't be boiling the mixture wouldn't
be boiling the boiling point actually
goes up and I think what you're going to
see when Joanne gives this lecture and
this is dangerous for me to see because
I have absolutely no idea what you're
going to say but anyway this will be
except that she's going to talk about
sugar is that is that you have to
control temperature very carefully
because what happens of course is that
that if you if you just dump heat in it
then the the thing starts to boil the
gas comes off and that of course means
that the sugar fraction increases which
makes the boiling point increase more
which makes the which makes the sugar
fraction increase even more and there's
a runaway phenomenon in this which is
the reason how many of you make candy
how many of you don't make candy okay
good the second which is the reason that
which is the reason that you have to buy
candy thermometers Joanne I don't think
needs a candy thermometer
so she'll explain to you how she gets
away with this presumably or if she
doesn't ask her so with no further ado
let me introduce Joanne so I actually it
always makes me very happy to introduce
Joanne for a number of different reasons
but one of them which for those of you
who have come here before you've heard
me say this but I'll just say it again
is that so Joanne was a Harvard
undergraduate and she was an applied
math major and I as it happens run the
applied math major I'm at Harvard and
I've always I've never I've never
understood why I was involved in the
science of cooking and Joanne though
well I mean she was an applied math and
she actually knows what she's doing and
so it sort of somehow made me feel good
so anyway with that Joanne thank you
thank you for that introduction I always
learned something from the introduction
that you give Michael you always explain
stuff so one of the reasons why I love
coming to these classes I'm a nervous
wreck the entire week before I still am
right now but in that quick five or ten
minutes that Michael speaks I always
learn a little bit more about what it is
that I do because I know how it works
and I can explain what will happen but I
didn't even think about what was
happening with the boiling point we are
going to boil sugar I'm going to show
you different things you can do with the
different stages of sugar but I didn't
even think about the actual boiling
point rising a little bit into the
lecture I will talk about the freezing
point of a liquid and how when you add
sugar to it it actually depresses the
freezing point but I hadn't thought
about how it works the other way so that
was really fun to learn so thank you
again for having me back
this year and thank your Harvard for
hosting this class and then I also have
to thank my assistant Jess who's back
there
piping lots of little containers of
buttercream and caramel sauce and little
crispy cookies for you guys to try at
the end so there there is a tasting hey
Jess
so the last two years that I've taught
here I focused very broadly on just the
chemistry of science and the chemistry
of baking science and baking and I
focused on making a cake what we did was
we took all the different ingredients
that go into a very simple yellow cake
and I talked about multiplication of
eggs I talked about gluten formation I
talked a little bit about buttermilk and
how it reacts differently than milk I
talked about all of the different ways
you can leaven a cake so with air and
with steam baking soda baking powder you
put all these things together mix them
all up and then you get cake and what we
did the last two years is we taught
about the science of baking through a
yellow cake these are some examples of
some of the cakes we did one with no
baking powder one with no baking soda we
did melted butter instead of
room-temperature butter we did a host of
different things and it was a super fun
lecture to teach turns out that last
year two of the students so I teach the
class tonight for the public and then
tomorrow I'll come back and teach to the
Harvard students were actually taking
this class as a course and two of the
students last year upon taking the
science and cooking class and then
watching the lecture that I taught about
cake for their final project I think it
was their final project they decided
they wanted to do more with cake and so
they came up with spray cake I don't
know if any of you guys saw this it was
actually in the globe about two or three
months ago it was front-page news that
these two Harvard students had come up
with a cake that you can put it they put
it in an aerosol can it sits on a shelf
in the grocery store and whenever you're
hungry and you want cake you just spray
this into a pan and then bake it and
then you get cake so this is for people
who think that cake mixes are too
difficult
and thus you just want to take an
aerosol can and spray it but they came
by the restaurant and they baked me some
cake they wanted me to approve it and
see if they if I thought it was good and
I thought it was really good and I have
to say it was really exciting to know
that something that I had taught had
actually led these students and inspired
them to create to create a product where
they're going to go off and make
millions so two questions lead lead from
that and when I told my parents about
this I sent it to them because my
picture was somewhere and they always
loved that kind of stuff the first thing
my mom said is are you getting royalties
on this so that I I still don't know I
haven't heard from them but they will
they might be here in this room or maybe
they'll watch the video and so they know
where to find me so you can you can
always you can always tag me along and
then the other question it raises is
that it really does up the ante for this
lecture and can I create a lecture that
will inspire people and make people
innovate something even more exciting so
a lot of pressure this time around ok so
this time professor Brenner and I talked
about focusing on a singular subject
rather than the broad topic of cooking
and baking and science and chemistry but
instead on just one subject and that is
sugar so this actually came at a great
time when professor Brunner called me
last year because I was just finishing
the manuscript for a new book that is
coming out next spring which is called
baking with less sugar and I just spent
the prior year baking all year long with
recipes that I was used to using at the
bakery but with less sugar or with no
sugar so I had a lot of experience
baking with less sugar or no sugar and
seeing the way the recipes came out when
you didn't have sugar so I was excited
to take everything that I've learned and
then share that with you guys so that
you can see all the things that you can
make with either no sugar or very little
sugar it turns out that sugar is
something that is genetically engineered
inside of us we are all born with an
affinity for sugar and if you have
something sweet in your mouth your body
reads it as a possible source of energy
and it reads it as probably not
something that's
to be harmful it doesn't read that when
it gets something sour or something
bitter and so having something that is
sweet is something that we are all
accustomed to and that we are all
attracted to so when you think about
sugar and what it does to desserts what
is it that defines a dessert
well it's got sugar in it there are very
few desserts out there that don't have
sugar you could have a dessert that's
fresh fruit that's what my parents did
they thought that was dessert I
disagreed or you could have some people
actually serve cheese as a last course I
don't know if some of you guys do that
I've always found that baffling but this
is also another way people end their
meal but really when we think about
sugar what we think about is all the
desserts that you can create with sugar
so what does sugar do to a dessert the
most obvious one if I were to ask all of
you is you would say it adds sweetness
it turns out and Jess and I spent all
afternoon thinking about this finishing
up this presentation it turns out that
chocolate is the only dessert that we
could think of in which sugar
the only role that sugar plays is to add
sweetness every other dessert we came up
with there was another role that sugar
played in making that dessert palatable
so I don't know I'm going to pose that
as a question to you guys think about
all the desserts that you know and if
you can think of a dessert in which
sugar the only role it's playing is to
make it palatable to your to your palate
and to make it sweet then I would love
to hear it because we had this blank at
first because we couldn't think of
anything that only had sugar to just add
sweetness because sugar plays so many
different roles in every sort of dessert
does anybody have any ideas can anybody
think of any dessert in which the only
reason you would have the sugar is to
add sweetness the slide that we had
anybody yes
milkshakes okay I'm going to come to
that in a little bit so I'm going to jot
down all of these in my head and then
we're going to address them yes exactly
so this was the only one bitter
chocolate and chocolate were the only
it's the only thing I can think of we
had one more which then we realized
there was actually another role that
sugar played so I'm looking to see if
anybody would yes
sorbet I'm actually goes along with
milkshakes sorbet and milkshakes the
sugar does add sweetness but it also
does something else yes
popsicles a sorbet and milkshakes all
the same yes said al there's going to be
another part where you're gonna see
where the sugar actually helps with the
satay on as well
pasta custard custard yep you need the
sugar for some another reason other than
other than sweetness one more thing
whipped cream actually whipped cream
you're right the only reason to have
sugar for whipped cream is to sweeten it
so that is I don't know if that counts
as a dessert but it is just like
chocolate it's something that's sweet
where the sugar is only okay one more
yes
sugared yogurt uh yeah you're right so
sugar in that case is just adding as
flavoring so you're dying to give one
more for the beautiful French macaroni
you definitely need sugar for reasons
other than just and I'll be demoing that
as well we're going to make meringue
that stabilizes the egg foams so it
turns out that sugar does so many other
things other than just add sweetness so
the first so I'm going to spend a little
time talking about the different roles
that sugar plays in various desserts and
then I'm going to go into the stages of
sugar we're going to take some sugar
syrups which are all up here and we're
going to take them to different stages
and you'll get to see how they react to
make different pastries so so now I'm
just going to go through kind of a
laundry list of what other things sugar
does to a dessert that makes it a
dessert so the first thing is creaming
sugar into butter so any cake recipe any
cook cook
recipe they almost all start out with
creaming butter and sugar together you
take granulated sugar you mix it into
butter and you cream it what's called
creaming in a mixer and you mix it and
mix it mix it until it becomes light and
fluffy in color and basically what's
happening is if I mean you guys all know
the texture of sugar it's very
granulated if you look at those granules
of sugar and under a microscope if
they're little itty bitty crystals and
the little sugar crystals have very hard
jagged edges and when they are mixed
with the butter or margarine or any sort
of solid fat what the sugar crystals are
doing is they are acting as they're
digging little air pockets into the fat
and so it's sort of like when you're a
gardener and you take a hoe and you're
hoeing the the firm earth and you're
aerating it that's exactly what happens
when you're creaming sugar and butter
together all of those air pockets then
go on when you're making your cake or
your cookie to make your final product
light and fluffy and tender and not hard
and dense so when you think about
cookies and you think about cakes you
need the sugar to make them taste sweet
but then you also need them in order for
them to be light and fluffy because of
the creaming properties so this is this
is from last year's lecture we have a
picture of a cake in which it's creamed
with a full amount of sugar and then we
used half amount of sugar and from the
pictures it doesn't look hugely
different but if you were to imagine a
six inch cake there's actually about an
inch to 1/2 an inch all the way through
the cake we noticed when we used half
the amount of sugar and it's because
there was half the amount of sugar
crystals to create those air pockets and
so then the final product wasn't able to
rise quite as much so the cake was a
little bit denser and it didn't rise
quite as much
another thing that sugar does is that
it's hydroscopic and what this means is
that it attracts water molecules that
are in the air and it brings it to
itself so this is one of the reasons why
you can take cookies and cakes and such
and you can package them and they can
sit on the shelf and they won't get
stale
because what the sugar does is it keeps
the moisture that's already in the
cookie inside the cookie and it helps it
last longer so you can put it on the
supermarket
and sell it for weeks at a time
originally when we were talking about
what is a desert in which the only thing
that sugar does is adds sweetness this
was the first slide that I had because I
thought well if he takes some fruit
and he mix a little bit of sugar into it
and you sweeten it then that's a desert
and the only thing the sugar is doing is
adding sweetness right well it turns out
not if you look at the picture closely
you can see in the the pot of
strawberries you can see a little bit of
that sauce that sauce is because sugar
is hydroscopic when it mixes with the
strawberries it's drawing out all the
moisture in the strawberries and it's
creating a sauce and so that's the other
way in which sugar helps make this
dessert so delicious it makes it sweet
and then it also combines with the
liquid and the strawberries to make a
sauce okay so the people who said
popsicle sorbet and milkshakes this is a
really interesting part about sugar that
I didn't know from a from a science
level
I just knew from an operational level
that when I used to make sorbets and ice
creams if I had something that didn't
have a lot of sugar it was really really
icy and if I had something in which I
had mismeasured and I put too much sugar
it was really soupy and I could never
really figure out why I just made sure
that I followed the recipe so that
wouldn't happen but in studying more
about the role of sugar and what it does
to desserts sugar actually depresses the
freezing point of a liquid so if we take
ice and we put it in the freezer you get
an ice cube right it's going to freeze
it zero degrees Celsius 32 degrees
Fahrenheit if you add some sugar to that
what it does is that it means that that
sugar water won't freeze right at zero
degrees Celsius but it might be a little
bit lower and so if you have a freezer
that's at zero degrees Celsius then that
sugar water that you have won't freeze
solid so we use this to our advantage
when we're making frozen desserts so
when you make a popsicle or sorbet or
milkshake you need the sugar to make it
taste good and to make it sweet but you
also need the sugar to make it actually
scoopable so that you can eat it so it's
not like sucking on a on an ice cube so
this is a video Jess made five versions
of grapefruit sorbet this is just
grapefruit and water there's no sugar
this version has a half a cup of sugar
and she wanted me to explain that she's
holding the iPhone with one hand and
she's trying which is why it looks like
it's really awkward because we were
watching and I was like why are you
looking so weird and she said it's
because I'm trying to hold the iPhone at
the same time
this is Version three one cup of sugar
this is the the actual recipe you can
see you can actually scoop into it this
is version four one and a half cups of
sugar and you can see that you can scoop
into it and you can see that it's
actually kind of melted because it's not
quite frozen and then finally this is
two cups of sugar this is twice the
amount of sugar that you should have in
this recipe and it's practically soup
you can see it's like really syrupy and
she doesn't even have to be so stiff
anymore so that's what sugar does to
popsicles sorbet and milkshakes that's
not only does it add the sweetness but
it also allows for a nice texture so
that you can eat it and it's and it's
easy to eat sugar also stabilizes beaten
egg foams so for the person who said
French macaron you need sugar
it adds sweetness but it also provides
the structure so that you can make the
the French knock hair home
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is just beat up the egg whites
without any sugar at all so like I was
saying you have the protein strands of
the egg whites are starting to get
filled with air and you're going to see
like this is egg whites before they're
beaten they're yellow they're viscous I
think you can start to see into the bowl
you can see how it's starting to get
white and airy that's because all of the
air is starting to get captured within
the foams now the protein of the egg
whites which is now capturing all the
air those protein strands aren't that
stable so I'm going to whip this and
whip this and with this and I'm going to
put this out in the bowl but you're
going to see it's going to be very
unstable it's going to look a little bit
like styrofoam and it's not going to be
anything that you're going to be able to
really bake with because it's going to
start to deflate we're going to do
another batch with egg whites and sugar
so sugar when I start to add that to the
egg whites the sugar actually combines
with the water that's in egg whites so
egg whites are protein strands and water
we're going to whip up the sugar into
the egg whites and in that batch the
sugar will combine with the water and
it's going to create a syrup within this
foam and what the syrup is going to do
is it's actually going to protect all of
the little protein bubbles that the egg
whites are forming when it goes into
foam and so it's sort of like packing
peanuts you know when you have something
fragile you buy all those little
styrofoam peanuts and you pack your
fragile items and you put lots of
peanuts around it to make sure it
doesn't break that's exactly what will
happen with the sugar so you can see
that now the egg white foam is all nice
and white and it's getting foamy and I
don't know if you can see but now it's
starting to get over whipped because
it's all of those proteins are being
stressed and stretched and stretched and
they're taking all the air they can can
they can and then they're just like okay
that's enough and then they start to
break down
so this one so this one can you tell how
I don't know if you can really see but
it's do you see how deflated it looks
and it's like it's just a matter of time
before all of this kind of deflates and
it doesn't look very I don't know I mean
to me this doesn't look very stable but
I don't know if you're not a baker if
you can tell that this isn't very stable
so is there nan Baker out there they can
look at this up
does this look stable to you you don't
know okay you're gonna have to take my
word for it this is not stable look at
it it's like see it just looks like it's
not going to last and then we're gonna
put it over here and you're gonna watch
it all night long and you'll see okay so
then we're gonna do the exact same thing
with the same amount of egg whites to
begin with but this time we're gonna add
so the key is you have to start it
really slow
so the same process is going to happen
it's going to start to get foamy
so while this is while I'm waiting to
add this these are the things that you
can make some of the things that you can
make with stabilized egg foams you can
make lemon meringue pie you can make
angel food cake you can make buttercream
on the slowly of the sugar so lemon
meringue pie you take this meringue that
I'm making and you plop it on a pie and
that's meringue for lemon meringue pie
angel food cake you take this exact
meringue that I'm making you're going to
see how easy baking is you're going to
fold in some cake flour and bake it and
that's angel food cake and then
buttercream again you're going to take
this exact meringue that I'm making and
you're going to throw butter into it and
then that's going to be buttercream so
those are some things that you can make
with sugar and egg foams so I'm gonna
let this go for a little bit and then
I'm going to show you the difference
between this one and that one so while
that's going I'm going to give you
another thing that sugar does sugar
tenderizes and inhibits gluten
development and I'm not going to go into
a big long thing about gluten but
basically gluten is a big buzzword
everybody knows about gluten it means
you want to avoid wheat gluten are two
protein molecules that exist in wheat
flour and they exist separately until
you add liquid to wheat flour as soon as
you add liquid to it the two protein
molecules bond together and then they do
exactly what the egg whites do is they
bond together and they form these
stretchy things that hold air so this is
great
when you have bread if you take bread
which is flour water and a couple other
things and you mix it up you develop all
this gluten and you create a bread
that's really chewy it has a lot of
great heft and tastes really great and
that's great for bread but when you're
making a cake that's the last thing in
the world you want is a cake that's
chewy and and not tender you want
something that's light and fluffy what
sugar does similar to what it does with
these egg foams
is that the sugar ends up protecting
those two protein gluten molecules from
from bonding and so when you're making a
cake batter if you have a lot of sugar
in it then the sugar is protecting those
from bonding and then you have a cake
that's tender and it doesn't have the
ability to hold all of these big pockets
of air which it will give you a chewy
cake let me show you this meringue so
this is very different so this was the
same one cup of I'm going to ask my
friend here does this look different so
do you see how silky that is where's the
camera it's like really silky and much
more stable and this is what you would
use to make a dessert with and that's
just the addition of sugar okay
okay I'm going to start getting these
things going that's that one and then
there's that one okay so a couple more
things and then we're going to start
talking about the stages of sugar so
sugar aids in browning so what this
means is at 310 degrees there are
protein molecules and sugars that
rearrange themselves in a cake batter or
a cookie or whatever into these little
ring lecture this is one of the things I
learned take getting ready for the class
it it they rearranged themselves into
these little ring like structures that
then reflect light differently to make
something look browner so this is a
picture of the sour cream coffee cake at
the bakery so it turns out for the new
low sugar baking book I made a sour
cream coffee cake this is the exact
recipe that we make at the bakery except
it has instead of a full cup of sugar it
has six tablespoons of sugar and you can
see the difference in color I mean
there's obviously going to be a
difference in taste but it was such a
drastic difference in color that when we
took this picture for the photo shoot
for the book and the photographer kept
trying to get me to put it in the oven
and brown it longer or he tried to
photoshop it to make it browner and we
knew that this wasn't a super attractive
picture because the one on the left is
what you're typically used to seeing
when you think about a beautiful cake
but the thing is is that when you don't
have a lot of sugar you're never going
to get that browning and so we wanted it
to be realistic and so this is the
picture something like this is what
you'll see in the book sugar makes
pastries crispy and so in something like
a cookie the sugar will liquefy it's in
the cookie batter it goes into the oven
it liquefies and then as the water
evaporates the sugar recrystallizes and
then you end up with the sugar with a
cookie that's really crispy so you're
going to get a little bit of a crispy
sugar cookie and it's crispy because of
the sugar again I tried to make a low
sugar sugar cookie for the book and it
was soft it wasn't that sweet but it was
also just soft and there was no way we
could get it to crisp up we ended up
doing a gingersnap and what we did was
rather than because it wouldn't crisp up
because it didn't have any sugar in it
we put it in an oven overnight and we
dried it out and then it ended up just
being a hard dehydrated cookie so it was
sort of crispy
I know that sounds really appetizing
doesn't it no it's really good
and then finally sugar caramelizes
between 356 degrees and 390 degrees
sugar will caramelize and that adds to
the flavor of a cookie or a cake or a
tart shell you get that really nice
toasty nutty aroma okay so the next
thing we're going to talk about is the
stages of sugar I'm going to come back
and babysit these guys so when you take
sugar and water and make it into a syrup
and you boil it at the various
temperatures that you boil the sugar
water to it corresponds to it
corresponds to the way the sugar reacts
in cold water and so the first stage is
thread stage this is the easy one you
just boil it at 230 degrees to 235
degrees it's called thread stage if you
pour a little bit of this into some
water you'll get little threads and then
it goes to the bottom this is used for
sweetening iced tea or just glazing
fruits the second stage is softball at
softball which is what I'm taking this
too you can make fudge I'm going to take
mine between softball and the next one
which is firm ball so at firm ball you
can make caramels so these are the
difference in temperatures I'm going go
backwards so if you look at softball to
35 to 240 when you take the sugar water
and you put it in cold water you'll get
a soft ball that's how it got its name
and then with firm ball when you do the
same thing you get a firm ball and
that's how so you don't need a candy
thermometer because you can just use
your hands but the thing is is that it's
really hot so you have to first freeze
your fingers so that and the other thing
that you can do and I don't know if you
can hear it because I'm talking but when
you hear sugar water boil it just sounds
like water at first and then as it
starts to get more and more concentrated
you can hear it and it starts to thicken
and when it gets to the right
temperature and this is only because
I've been doing it for you
Cheers you can actually tell when it's
hitting about softball stage so that way
you don't have to plunge your finger in
all the time you can wait so can you
hear it it's a little bit slower now so
now I'm going to take a little bit and
now I've gone a little bit too far no
here here we go firm ball you can't
really see that but there's a firm
little ball okay now we're going to make
meringue so this is very similar
to the meringue that we made that's
sitting over there in that bowl except
that I've cooked the sugar this will
help make it that meringue is not quite
as stable as this meringue
so I've just taken that sugar syrup and
I've poured it into the egg whites I'm
going to take this Italian meringue and
I'm going to throw butter into it and
then that's butter cream and that's what
you use to frost a cake and that's what
you're going to eat is a little little
bit of buttercream okay so but you have
to wait until this cools before you can
add the butter so while that's cooling
I'm going to go back to the slide really
quick hardball you is to what you use to
make marshmallows and then soft crack is
taffy hard crack is lollipops and then
the final stage is caramelization and
that's when you take the sugar so far
that it starts to turn tan and then it
starts to turn brown and you can make
praline and caramel sauce and a whole
bunch of other things so does that make
sense all of the stages of sugar and why
they have the different names okay
because because it's you can definitely
use a candy thermometer but if you know
what you're looking for you can you
don't have to and you can just use ice
water and then you'll know exactly how
far to take it okay so let's revisit
these meringues you can see this one so
can you see this is the one that was
just egg white and no sugar and it's
basically just deflating in front of our
very eyes it's very sad
useless this has been stabilized with
sugar so you can see it's still
beautiful you can make cookies out of
this you could fold almond flour and
make French macaron that's what you
would use this for the Italian one which
is over there we're going to wait until
it cools and then this one we are going
to make praline praline is when you take
sugar and you wait until it caramelizes
so right now it's reaching about firm
ball hard ball because it's really
really slow in its bubbles and the
bubbles are getting really big they're
very yeah very slow and now it'll slowly
start to turn color and as soon as it
starts to caramelize to make praline you
just pour nuts into it and then pour it
out onto a sheet tray and then let it
cool
okay so while that one is waiting to
caramelize we're going to add the butter
to this one sorry I don't mean to keep
moving around but can you see how much
this is grown I don't know if you guys
can see that so to make buttercream you
just take the butter and you just throw
it in
it's got to be soft butter it can't be
too cold or it'll shock the whole thing
but it can't be melted butter because
then it won't be stable enough and it's
about a cup of egg whites a cup of sugar
and a pound of butter
it sound like a lot I feel like this is
such a small amount like I'm almost done
and what will happen is is the butter
will slowly mix into the meringue and
it's going to look broken at first it's
going to look like we messed up and then
slowly it'll all come together and then
we'll have butter cream okay
so that one is working and now we're
going to come back here and now you can
see you see that how nice that looks
so I'm just going to swirl this around a
little bit and then add my nuts squirrel
to coat
and probably about 10 or 15 minutes will
cool and it'll be really hard and then
you can break it off and some people can
eat it because we only have this much so
we'll put it right there we're going to
make caramel sauce and then we're going
to finish with croquembouche which is
the picture that the the beginning of
the slideshow began with so right now
I'm just adding water to the sugar to
dissolve it and then we're going to take
it just as far as we took that
and this one we're waiting to get a
little bit Brown so that we can make
caramel sauce okay
so here we go we're going to look at the
buttercream and so this is buttercream
and this is what you would use to frost
a cake so if you want you can make this
ahead of time I know this is a baking
class but just so you know if you want
you can make this ahead of time store it
in the fridge and then when you want to
reuse it you don't want to use this you
actually want to use this to reap a ttle
it and to make it smooth again it's
going to be hard like butter because
it's mostly butter so you're going to
want to bring it to room temperature and
paddle it and it might break it might
look curdled but just wait until it
warms up and then when you paddle it
it'll get smoothing in and then you can
use it any questions no okay because we
just have to wait for these two things
the timing with caramel is a little bit
tricky so we're waiting for this to
caramelize and then we're going to do
the croquembouche with this um that's
all I have yeah yeah again so I mean if
you noticed on Joanne slides as she was
going from softball to hardball to
whatever they're called what was
increasing was the percentage of sugar
that's in the thing and it's really
dramatic that is only a couple of
degrees and the sugar percentage goes up
from like eighty-five to ninety-five
percent so what's the rest of it other
than sugar what else is in there when it
says eighty-five percent sugar what else
is in the mixture water and so the
reason that the textures are so
different is because you knew you know
if it's all sugar it'll be really hard
but see if 95 percent sugar
the texture is softer 92% it's softer so
what you're really doing is controlling
the water content of the of the mixture
so we're going to now make caramel sauce
so you can see that it's now nice and
caramelized and one trick again I know
it's not a baking class but just in case
you guys decide to make something when
you make caramel right now it looks
really Brown but the grill key is what
you want to do is actually tilt the pan
and then look at the what's what results
because that's the true color so I think
a lot of bakers they think oh this is
caramel I'm done but no this isn't this
isn't dark enough what you want to do is
take it tilt it and then look and then
that fine sheen is how is the true color
okay now it's good and then we're going
to add cream but you have to be really
careful because it's okay and that's
caramel sauce okay and then this one is
the last one which is I'm going to do
what's called spinning sugar and that's
taking caramel and then creating because
remember how we talked about softball
firm ball hard ball soft crack hard
crack it turns out at hard crack and
beyond what that means is that when the
sugar cools it becomes like a crack it
cracks and caramel which is way past
hard crack when you flick it really fast
it creates these long sugar strands that
end up looking very beautiful and that's
spun sugar and last year when I did it I
had a pot of sugar and it crystallized
in the middle of the lecture and it was
like what do I do
so crystallization of sugar is when
you're doing what we've been doing you
put sugar and water in a pot and you
turn it on and you think you're making
you know either softball for a
buttercream or you're making caramel for
caramel sauce and you come and you look
at it and all of a sudden I was actually
worried that that might happen tonight
but I probably should have let it happen
so that I could show you guys so when
you come back and you look at it turns
out it starts to have what I don't even
know how to describe it it kind of looks
like pieces of ice floating in the sugar
syrup so everything that you've seen has
been perfect everything's boiled this
looks so perfect it's just boiling and
boiling
but it turns out there's a couple things
that cause crystallization that I know
of from a pastry point of view I don't
really know what it means from a from a
scientific point of view but if you have
any sugar crystals that are on the side
of the pan so when you take sugar and
water and you mix them together you
don't want to splash sugar crystals on
the side so you you may have noticed
that when I put the water and I didn't
just pour the water and I very gently
put the water in
I really gently moved the sugar to
dissolve it because if there's any sugar
crystals on the side then there's a
chance that those sugar crystals they're
very influential and when this is
happening it's at this point when it
starts to go into softball form ball
stage that if there's a sugar crystal
the sugar crystal will fall into the
syrup and it'll just cause this chain
reaction that will then cause what looks
like ice on the top of it
and it can happen at any stage the other
times it happens is if you move it so I
don't know if you've noticed but I won't
touch this until it starts to caramelize
so if you move the sugar syrup while
it's spoiling it for some reason jostles
it and makes it want to crystallize and
so those are two tricks you want to make
sure that there's no sugar on the edge
of the pan and then you don't want to
touch it until it caramelizes as soon as
it caramelizes you can touch it and you
can swirl it around and even out the
caramelization but before then if you
touch it there's a chance it will
crystallize some things that you can do
you can try to just boil it gently and
sometimes it boils away but a lot of
times you just have to start over and so
like during the holidays when we're
making millions and millions of
croquembouche
we have pots of sugar just going on
every stove because one out of every 10
ends up crystallizing and then we can't
use it so we always have all these
back-up pots is that how good yeah I
think let's let's do this for a sec so
the sugar actually started to
crystallize which is too bad but okay so
now you can see so this is caramel right
we were we've made it we've let it sit
and now it's starting to cool down and
as it cools it thickens up and then so
what I'm doing is I keep lifting it and
to see if it'll just fall in one
continuous strand without breaking and
then once I feel like it's a nice thick
layer I'm gonna try not to make too much
of a mess
way so then what you can do is just do
what's called sponger which is you
basically
so I let a lot of it drip off because I
don't want clumps of it and then I just
flick and you can see that it just
starts to fall because it's past that
soft crack stage I mean there's a lot of
different ways you can do this and
typically you should do this on like a
piece of parchment it makes cleanup a
little bit easier I'll do that tomorrow
I forgot I'm sorry okay and then so this
is just the start of it so then you can
take all of this sponge sugar and just
wrap it around here I'll get this slice
of it but it's super easy you just hold
this and then you flick so you have to
flick it's a really quick quick flicking
so a lot of times people do this I'm
going to show you what not to do so a
lot of times people will do this okay
but what you want to do is again let a
lot of it run off and then just flick
really fast and then as the sugar falls
from the utensil it'll form these
strands that then become spun sugar and
so then as this gets colder it becomes
harder to spin because the the sugar
gets more and more firm and hard and
then you can do what's called pulled
sugar actually you would never take it
to caramel to do pulled sugar but if you
take sugar to a hard crack stage and
then let it cool it becomes it becomes a
stiffer as it cools and as it becomes
stiffer you can start to lift it up and
it starts to feel like caramel and you
can start to pull it and that's how they
make all those beautiful like flowers
and birds and butterflies and stuff like
that so yeah so this is you just keep
going until you cover it and as much
caramel as you want the tricky thing
about croquembouche and about spun sugar
is that it's very temperature dependent
it's very humidity dependent and so you
actually can make it it will last for
about an hour
to two hours and then it just starts to
melt and if it's raining outside you
don't even have that long you probably
have like 15 minutes and then it just
starts to melt can I ask you guys a
question so why do you have to click it
anybody know it has to it has to hit our
air so somebody said cool rapidly so
when you flick it I think you evaporate
the liquid out faster and it solidifies
faster if you go like this it doesn't
evaporate so probably it's liquid when
it comes down if you don't flick it I
think because as it cool so if I just
take it and just move it so you're just
poured yeah and then it's just pouring
so it's not really this like it's and
you move something so there's this
wonderful thing experiment we've all
done if you blow on a spoon that's hot
it cools faster and if you let it and
that's because it evaporated that you
carry the heat away fast yeah should
evaporates faster okay so should we so I
think we should take more questions let
me propose several things first I think
we should all clap
you